if you want to get to the opposite end
of the world it's a hike about 20,000
kilometers but what if you didn't have
to travel across the surface what if you
could dig straight through to the other
side if you're trying to dig to China
from the US there's something you should
know first the opposite point on the
planet isn't in China it's somewhere in
the middle of the Indian Ocean so to get
to China
you should start digging in either
Argentina or Chile your first challenge
would be digging through the Earth's
crust it's the thinnest of Earth's three
main layers yet humans have never
drilled all the way through it as you
descend you'd soon reach the depth of
the Paris catacombs the deepest metro
station and the devil worm the deepest
animal we've ever discovered underground
then it would start to get hot at 4,000
meters down you pass the deepest mine on
the planet which is cooled with ice to
make workers comfortable because down
here
temperatures are 60 degrees Celsius by
eight thousand eight hundred meters
you'll be as deep as Mount Everest as
tall but it's still not the deepest
point humans have ever dug that point is
at the bottom of the Kola super-deep
borehole at 12,000 260 meters below the
surface down here there's 4,000 times
more pressure than at sea level and
temperatures push a hundred eighty
degrees Celsius so you'd need a lot of
insulation to carry on and keep from
melting at around 40,000 meters you'd
reach Earth's second and largest layer
the mantle which makes up a whopping 84%
of the planet's volume near the border
temperatures climb to around 1,000
degrees Celsius hot enough to melt many
metals like silver but not a steel drill
and good thing because you'll need it to
drill through the first part of the
mantle which is made of solid rock until
you reach a hundred thousand meters that
is when you might need to switch to a
propeller here the pressure and
temperature are so high that in some
places rock takes on a
like consistency in fact it's this rock
that ultimately erupts from volcanoes on
the surface at a hundred fifty thousand
meters
keep your eyes peeled for diamonds they
form when heat and pressure restructure
the carbon atoms in this region but once
you reach four hundred and ten thousand
metres the rock is solid again so it's
back to the drill you see while it's
still plenty hot at this depth to melt
rock the pressure is so extreme that the
molecules inside literally can't move
into a liquid state then by three
million meters down you'd reach Earth's
third layer the outer core unlike
Earth's crust and mantle the core is
made of iron and nickel temperatures
here are the same as the surface of the
Sun hot enough to melt all that metal so
yep back to the propeller and it would
have to be made out of some kind of
super material because no known element
has a melting point above 6000 degrees
Celsius making matters worse the outer
core also has low gravity because when
you're that deep much of the planet's
mass is now above you which produces a
gravitational force that pulls away from
the center so to continue you need a
super heat and pressure proof submarine
that moves like Rockets in space by
shooting fuel out the back end you'd
soon arrive at the inner core around
five million meters below the surface
the inner core is one giant sphere of
solid iron so it would definitely be
challenging to get through but if you
did find a way you'd soon hit the
halfway point about six point four
million meters down also known as the
center of the earth
now there's nearly the same amount of
mass all around you pulling you equally
in all directions so there's zero
gravity here and now is when the trip
really gets hard the second half because
as you dig past the inner core you'd
soon feel the pull of gravity again and
this time it'd be pulling you from above
where the majority of Earth's mass is
now
so while you might be digging down
relative to where you started
it'll feel like you're climbing up and
if you didn't have those handy Rockets
propelling you you'd fall right back to
the core but 6.4 million meters later
after powering through impenetrable iron
molten alloy and solid and mushy rock
you'd arrive at long last on the other
side in China that would certainly come
as a relief but it wouldn't even be the
best part
assuming you left a tunnel through the
center of the earth behind you you'd now
be able to travel back and forth between
China and Argentina in under an hour
simply by jumping in to learn why check
out another video we made about jumping
to the center of the earth
you